-Every night on our show,
I deliver a monologue
comprised of jokes written by
a diverse team of writers.
As a result, a lot of jokes
come across my desk that,
due to my being
a straight, white male
would be difficult for me
to deliver.
But we don't think that should
stop you from enjoying them,
so we'd like to share them
with you now in a segment called
"Jokes Seth Can't Tell."
♪♪
These are two of our writers,
Amber and Jenny.
-I'm black.
-And I'm gay.
-And we're both women.
-And I'm not.
So, here's how it works.
I'll read the setups
to these jokes,
and Amber and Jenny
will read the punch lines.
Here we go.
Clothing store J. Crew
announced recently
they will file for bankruptcy.
-Said lesbians,
"We did our part."
-Well, you still have
L.L. Bean.
-True.
Fun fact about L.L. Bean --
the "L.L." stands for
lesbian, lesbian.
-Oh, I had no idea.
Activists recently painted
"Black Lives Matter"
on Fifth Avenue
outside of Trump Tower.
-And because it was in
the middle of Fifth Avenue,
Trump shot it.
-Amber, do you think
Trump was mad
when he saw that
written on the street?
-No.
He doesn't know how to read.
He thinks it says
"Blake Lively matters."
And he loves it.
-Yeah.
A lesbian couple recently both
gave birth three days apart.
-And only two weeks
after meeting each other
and moving in together.
-So, Jenny,
you make a lot of jokes
about how lesbians
move in together quickly.
Do you do that?
-Oh, no, I always wait
until the third date.
-Aw, that's very patient.
Researchers at
Stanford University
are working on a smart toilet
that can identify
the user's butt.
-So, expect an error message,
white women!
[ Robotic voice ] "Warning!
Warning! No butt detected!"
-Wait.
The toilet seat has arms, Amber?
-[ Normal voice ]
It gets up and walks to you
when you have to poop.
[ Laughter ]
-To prevent the spread of
the coronavirus,
health experts are recommending
that people
keep their fingernails short.
-"Way ahead of you,"
said lesbians.
-Jenny, do you want to explain
that joke to viewers?
-Nah, they'll finger it out.
-[ Laughs ]
I just fingered it out.
[ Laughter ]
Aunt Jemima pancake mix
will be given a new logo
because the original was
based on black stereotypes.
-"I still like the one about us
having big [bleep], though,"
said Uncle Ben.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, I got to start looking at
these ahead of time.
[ Laughter ]
-We're too unsupervised.
-According to a new
Congressional report,
women should be eligible
for the draft.
-Said the military, "Well, we
would save a lot on payroll."
-Last month, Mississippi
retired their state flag,
which included the image of
a Confederate symbol.
-But they replaced it
with the image
of a black person
being denied a loan.
-Hey, Seth, why don't you
tell one?
-Oh, guys, I really don't think
I should.
-Oh, come on, just one.
-No. I feel like if I do it,
it won't end well.
-Do it!
-Come on.
-Alright, fine.
Because I trust and believe
you guys
and you wouldn't lie to me
during a pandemic.
According to a new report, sales
of bras dropped last month.
Also dropping -- boobs.
-How dare you!
-You both told me
it would be okay!
-You should be ashamed
of yourself.
-Black women and lesbians
are liars!